I go to lay down and as soon as I close
my eyes I see the Matrix I see all like
a binary code like ones and zeros ones
and zeros and I was like I'm just tired
I'm just tired yeah and then from there
I I opened my eyes and my hand was like
uh you ever seen a goofy movie
um I was literally everything was the
same color in the same animation as the
Goofy movie like I literally felt like I
was in a cartoon and I was like oh boy
[ __ ] here we go
before we get started this episode is
brought to you by nordvpn nord's virtual
private Network hides your data in an
encrypted tunnel so that you can be
online without risking the Integrity of
your personal information when you sign
up for nordvpn you can have your own
personal IP address assigned to you that
will conceal your real IP address I'm
not sure how this is allowed exactly but
it's a sweet deal did you ever get those
emails warnings when you were a kid
about downloading content I used to get
them when I was 12 or 13 and they just
terrified me to my core which is why I
use nordvpn securing your IP address can
also help protect any payments or money
transfers that you make online you can
also use nordvpn's dedicated IP address
to keep Hackers from infiltrating your
devices other than your computer and
phone which is something I just learned
can happen doorbell cameras smart
thermostats and smart home systems can
all be hacked by people who want to
infiltrate your devices and steal your
information
if you get nord's dedicated IP address
not only will your information be
protected on your phone and computer but
up to six of your devices can be secured
through nord's encrypted Network tunnel
simultaneously nordvpn Shields you
against anyone who wants to exploit your
online movement so go grab your nordvpn
deal today over at nordvpn.com
tmpp I hate that acronym the Michaela
Peterson podcast promo code tmpp for 61
off their Premium plan and their free
anti-malware feature all with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee I hope you
enjoy this episode
Dave Sparks welcome to my podcast I'm
okay let's get to see you again yeah
good to see you too how are you doing
really well yeah actually
um I can honestly say never better
wow okay I feel like I feel the same way
that's you look great you actually look
really really healthy it's crazy to see
your evolution of you know obviously
you've come a long ways from when you
were really sick and then your progress
has been phenomenal thanks when when did
we talk that was a oh it's been probably
almost two years yeah okay so you we
spoke when I was like taking care of my
dad and in a rough spot right so I think
you were overseas you were somewhere
yeah you were definitely weren't in the
country Serbia or something yeah you've
been married since yeah yeah I think
things are drastic have drastically
improved so before I mean we're started
but for anyone who doesn't know who you
are can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
yeah uh basically I'm a guy living the
American dream I uh I've started a few
different businesses over the years and
every business that I've started has
basically provided me with an
opportunity it started as a hobby right
and they say don't make your hobby your
profession because you'll get tired of
it and that's one thing that hasn't
happened to us so basically in a
nutshell because this is a really hard
question to answer people ask me this
whole time in fact people ask my wife
and my kids and nobody really knows how
to answer it
um I am in the
I'm an Entertainer in the automotive
World
um that's kind of where we got started
and we had a TV show on Discovery
Channel uh we still do I started filming
in 2015. it's called diesel Brothers we
are on season number eight so nine I
can't remember they'll kind of Blended
together so our new season comes out in
October and then we're also uh YouTube
content creators we are
um
search and rescue kind of professionals
we we um we volunteer time and services
to be able to go help find missing
people
um you know extract large vehicles and
equipment from dangerous situations so
that's crazy yeah we do a little bit of
everything but basically everything we
do we just document and we film it and
people love it so uh that's a very very
long answer to a short question but uh
that's kind of what we do
so how did you go from so your business
was diesel Sellers and you you started
that how did that get transformed into a
TV show so it's interesting we started
the business back in 2012 and in 2012
Facebook didn't really have any rules or
algorithms or I mean it was just kind of
a wild west out there and if you posted
something it could go viral with no you
know no reason behind it so we started
this page about trucks because we
originally
um bought and sold trucks and we still
do that's one of my businesses we have a
truck dealership but basically we would
take the trucks that we were buying for
resale and we would post videos of them
because these were unique trucks uh
unique vehicles and we would put those
videos on Facebook and the video started
getting like hundreds of thousands of
views like overnight and so we realized
that we were onto something so we took
that and we built it into a community a
Facebook Community which was called like
diesel trucks for sale or something and
I realized that wasn't a very catchy
business name so we came up with a
diesel seller's business name and that
turned into less focused on the trucks
and more focus on us as the guys that
were driving them and showing them and
doing these these goofy things and so we
took that a step further and started
creating YouTube content which was like
pranks with the trucks and uh pretty
much anything Automotive related but not
only Automotive related it was it was
Automotive meets lifestyle and we had a
couple of videos that went uh crazy
viral and Jay Leno originally saw one of
those videos and he called us and he's
like hey this prank is hilarious I love
it I want to have you guys on my show
yeah it was wild so he had us on the
show on a segment that he used to do
called prank you very much and the day
after that show aired our phone just
started ringing non-stop from different
networks all over the place and we
really didn't want a TV show because we
had heard all the horror stories about
you know these people it's like the guy
at the mall that gives you his card
right and he's like hey I'm gonna make
you a model and make it famous and we're
like that's we we didn't believe that
that was something that could actually
happen or or on the other side of it we
didn't want to become the Kardashians we
didn't want to become these people that
were uh you know make being made look
silly on TV until one day Discovery like
one of the top producers called us
because we've been blowing them off
forever and uh this guy says hey I want
you guys to know did we were discovered
like we're not some talent agency we're
not we are discovering corporate and
we're gonna guarantee you guys eight
shows
in the season and all you have to do is
just let us come film and so at that
point I was like okay let's take a look
more seriously they came out uh filmed a
pilot loved us and we just started
filming and never stopped so that's
that's kind of how that evolved and out
of that TV show we've created a bunch of
different spin-off uh both on YouTube
online Facebook and on TV a bunch of
different
um uh series and you know it was
originally all based around the trucks
but
my goal was to Branch out of that just
because trucks are cool and I love them
but I that's like this much of my life I
I do so many other things and so that's
kind of how the TV show was born uh when
it aired on TV or on a Discovery Channel
back in January 2016. it was their
number one new series premiered that had
aired like in 50 years or something it's
a crazy number yeah so the show did
really well and they originally were
hoping that the show would
you know go into the automotive Niche
and and
kind of cater to those 35 to 65 year old
men who wanted to watch Cars and Trucks
get fixed but it quickly became a family
show it became a show that moms and dads
and kids and basically everyone from the
babies to the grandparents were watching
together because it wasn't just about
trucks it was about us and our lives and
our families and the stuff that we do
and the goofy you know pranks and things
like that so it uh it became something
that was never intended to be but it
became exactly what I
would have hoped it to become uh if that
makes any sense because uh like I said
just working on trucks and cars it's
that's that's it's too little for me I
think bigger than that I guess
yeah I can kind of understand the like
the concern about being niched into one
area right and the thing is you need a
niche to get started and the trucks are
kind of where that Catalyst that got us
out there and you know people started
recognizing us and then from there
it's just all just a matter of what you
do with it and how you have you
leveraged that platform and we've been
uh we've been fortunate enough to
leverage it in ways that other
Automotive creators and and uh you know
TV show Talent didn't do uh yeah and got
stuck
yeah there's actually something to that
right you can get your one shot at kind
of popularity and then there are things
you have to do to keep that going or to
grow it right otherwise you can just
fade away right exactly so that's the
that's the thing that I didn't want to
have happen see
I think so many people and this is this
is a this is a important point for kind
of everybody right now anybody who's
trying to become relevant or an
influencer or anything like that the
harder you try to be relevant the less
successful you're going to be
um because it's obvious right you see
those people that are out there
constantly doing things to try to get
people's attention and a lot of times
they're doing things that aren't natural
to them uh they're doing things that
they think people want to see but if the
camera wasn't rolling they might not be
doing that specific thing and it's
obvious they're acting and so are we
we're not actors we're legitimately just
guys with a lot of different interests
and we have the resources and the
ambition and sometimes stupidity to
pursue these things and it's worked
people can tell that it's natural it's
authentic and there's been times where
we've kind of gone dark on both social
media and TV because we weren't really
doing anything that we felt we needed to
share at that time and I think that is
where you see people
able to step up the next level because
it's growth right you can't
like you were saying if you get stuck in
that same world for too long you become
stagnant you become stale and you have
two options either just disappear and
become completely irrelevant or try too
hard and continue to try to like be
front and center and neither one of
those were great options for us and so
we just decided to keep living and a
growing and doing new things and when we
found something we were excited about we
turned the camera on and it worked
fair enough
um okay I have a question so in 2012
when you when you started the shop did
you have any like outline for your life
or have you kind of just gone with the
flow like becoming kind of famous was
that random or were you striving towards
that
so one thing about me is
I'm not a great planner
um and it's not that I don't have the
ability to plan it it's that I don't
like to because I have a very dangerous
uh skill but I didn't really know that I
had back then and it's the ability to
like we were just talking you know
before we got started to manifest things
really quickly and so if I think about
something if I think about it for more
than five or ten minutes it's done and
it happens subconsciously this thing all
these things come to me
without me working towards them without
me saying okay today I'm gonna I'm gonna
get this I'm gonna get that it's just I
want this I want that thing so bad and I
I one thing I'm really good at is
visualizing myself having the things
that I want
um and I didn't you know this has all
become kind of mainstream now right
you've got the you've got the secret the
the secret The Law of Attraction all
these different things that people talk
about and I remember
2010 2011. a friend of mine introduced
me to the the secret right that's like
the the kindergarten where everybody
starts in the world of personal
development and I remember watching it I
was like
this is weird because this is what I do
I didn't know I had a name I didn't know
there was a process I just pictured what
I wanted I would feel the emotion of
what I would accomplish that goal even
though I was years away like I used to
here's a good example I used to drive
down the road in my car or my truck and
I one day went and uh did a demo flight
in a helicopter and I became obsessed
with helicopters well I grew up
um lower middle class you know my my dad
was sick all growing up we didn't have a
ton of money and so a kid like me
shouldn't have had Ambitions or or not
necessarily Ambitions but shouldn't have
thought that he was gonna be able to own
a helicopter anytime soon but I went
into demo flight and fortunately after
the demo flight I mean the the place
where I went was like hey you should
become a pilot professional pilot get
you trained and it was like 80 grand and
fortunately I couldn't afford it at the
time and I say fortunately because I
would have hated to become a
professional pilot it wouldn't be able
to take all the fun out of it so uh
anyways I would drive up and down the
road in my truck and I would pretend
like I was driving or flying the
helicopter after that experience because
it was so cool to me and I just wanted
to like put my stuff in that mindset and
it wasn't it wasn't necessarily
intentional at the time saying okay if I
do this you know two years from now I'm
gonna have a helicopter I just really
enjoyed the thought of like man this
feels like I'm playing a helicopter how
would it feel if I actually had my own
uh 2016 I bought my first helicopter um
helicopters aren't you know they're not
cheap and they're not easy to to get
into that world and this was you know
five years after my first experience
with one I was able to go buy one and
since then
I that's all I do is helicopters I love
helicopters I've got all sorts of
different helicopters in fact I just
bought a um Blackhawk helicopter from
the US Army wow one of the only
privately owned privately used
Blackhawks in existence I mean they buy
them and they buy fires with them but I
bought it to fly my family around
so that's just amazing yeah it's really
cool so I when I heard about vision
boards you know you've heard this uh
everybody talks about that
I was like okay that's something I
should do so I went to the internet and
I pulled off a bunch of pictures of
things that I loved or I wanted or I
thought were cool and I you know made a
collage this was back in 2011 2012. uh
and I I ordered it from some company
online and they sent me a big poster of
it and I hung it up and it was cool but
I didn't spend a ton of time like
looking at it every day it's just those
things were things that I wanted and
somehow deep down inside I knew that I
could get well
2015 2016 I looked at the vision board
it was like wrapped up in my closet in
fact we were done filming with Discovery
one day and I was cleaning out my office
closet and I came across my whole vision
board which had since been rolled up and
tucked away
and I was like I should look at that
pulled it up every single item on that
board oh that's I had already
accomplished is wild so
to answer your question I don't look too
far into the future because it's
dangerous for me
um
if I think about wanting to own
something
I'm going that direction whether I like
it or not so I have to be careful now
now that I understand the power that I
have and the the way that my my
subconscious works I have to be very
careful with the things that I put right
there because if I'm going for something
over here but I put this right here is
something I really want I'm feeling the
emotions of accomplishing that goal
you better believe I'm going that
direction and it might Sidetrack me from
going this way so uh oh I like that
interesting okay I like that that would
have sounded way out there to me
uh probably a while ago now probably
more like eight years ago right but I've
had similar strange experiences now
nothing to the degree of like helicopter
but um I had my dad was always very set
on goal setting right like write out
what you want and then aim towards it
and you'll get there right but I always
thought that was because when you think
about something then subconsciously you
work towards it whether or not you're
thinking about it right and that could
be part of it but I I did have an
experience um right before Dad got
really sick I wrote out I was like what
do I want I've got some opportunity here
I didn't have very much money but I was
like I'll work really hard what what do
I want
and I wrote like 12 things about what I
wanted and then put my journal away and
then Dad got really sick and I didn't
look at that journal for another year
and a half and I really had spent most
of my time taking care of my dad so I
hadn't been focusing on work at all
really but I had accomplished all the
things I'd written down in the journal
right and I was like oh that's really
strange right because I it wasn't
something I looked at every day it was
something that I'd thought of like once
was like no I really want these but I
don't really have time right now because
I was taking care of dad
um there's definitely like I don't
exactly know how reality works but it's
definitely strange right so I see what
you're saying the thing is it's not it's
not reality because reality is is what
most people grow up thinking you got to
set goals and you got to work towards
them and you know you're slowly checking
things off that list
um you know the the real reality of of
how things work and how people that are
ambitious and have the ability to
manifest things that all happens
like I said subconsciously it happens
without us knowing it but it's deep down
inside of us I think it I think it boils
down to emotions
um
if you can feel something you can have
it even if you don't have it and this is
that's a it's a pretty Elementary
concept but if you really dig into it uh
you know take for example anxiety
there's a lot of people that struggle
with anxiety and fear and you know you
know borderline depression even if
they're not clinically diagnosed
well one day when I was talking to a
friend who had you know he was talking
to me about some anxiety that he had and
some issues
I was hearing him out and after the
conversation I said listen this may
sound crazy and you know no offense but
your anxiety sounds a lot like
excitement to me because the emotion
is kind of the same if you think about
it if you're excited about something you
get those butterflies you get like your
heart rate you know increases and you
get kind of in a go mode well anxiety
does the same type of thing
physiologically to you you know your
heart rate increases but the problem is
it's how you're framing it so I learned
uh I just kind of learned this on my own
and later on confirmed through you know
different teachings that anxiety and
excitement can be the same thing it just
depends on how you frame it in your mind
and what you turn that thought and that
that feeling into so if I was ever
feeling anxious I can take that uh
anxiety and I can turn it into
excitement or one of my goals it's just
a matter of what I'm thinking about if
I'm anxious about you know in the early
days of our business making payroll and
being concerned I could turn that
anxiety into an excitement for when we
got you know paid on a big deal or
whatever it was and it was a small shift
but instantly my day would become better
and I would just not allow those
negative thoughts that were attached to
that emotion to be there instead I would
just move a positive thought over to the
same emotion the same feeling and boom
everything just got better easier and
less resistance I think that's
ultimately what it boils down to is
if you focus on Resistance you're gonna
run into a hell of a lot of resistance
it's just that's just the way it goes
you know it's so funny and people think
that this is uh people think sometimes
that these concepts are voodoo or a
little bit out there and uh I disagree
completely because have you ever like we
were talking with with the queen you
were literally just yesterday thinking
about that now does that mean that you
put the queen in the hospital no but
that means that there was very unpopular
some sort of wavelength that connected
there for you and you kind of felt or
knew or thought of something before it
even happened because you know whatever
happened to her was going to happen
a long time ago you just caught you
caught a whole day yeah I think that
wavelength that yeah that frequency you
caught a hold of it that I really think
that's the absolute truth and it's no
different than a radio in your car when
you change the channel you're catching
different frequencies or which are
different songs well that's something
that a man invented right or you know
people created a radio and that's
something that's primitive and simple
imagine the things that we can't see and
that we don't understand they're out
there I think we're just giant antennas
basically once I learned that everything
changed
wow that's really cool
this episode of the podcast was
sponsored by paleo Valley's beef sticks
fantastic sponsor if you want to lose
weight be hotter eat beef sticks instead
of junk
tastes better it's more filling it
doesn't fill you up but keep you hungry
it just fills you up
who doesn't want beef sticks nobody's
sane anyway paleo Valley is my go-to
company for my kid for beef sticks paleo
Valley's beef sticks are made from 100
grass-fed and finished beef they have
very limited ingredients other than that
not only are there cows grass-fed but
the spices they use to flavor their beef
sticks are also 100 organic and is all
produced right here in the U.S
paleo Valley also puts their beef sticks
through a natural fermentation process
which like other fermented foods is very
good for your microbiome each of these
factors help make Paleo Valley beef
sticks the cleanest most gut friendly
beef sticks on the market and a snack
you can eat that will fill you up won't
make you crash and is healthy head over
to paleoballey.com to check out their
beef sticks today that's
p-a-l-e-o-v-a-l-l-e-y.com for 100
grass-fed beef sticks and an excellent
snack I hope you enjoy the rest of this
episode okay this is this is side note
have you done psychedelics before so I
have done Ayahuasca
um I did it once I had a group of
friends that uh was kind of way into it
and I watched a couple of friends change
drastically they um you know they went
from having lots of emotional issues and
they started getting better and I
noticed it and I called them you know
call them out and said hey what's going
on what are you doing what's different
and they told me about the Ayahuasca
journey and uh I thought it was super
fascinating
um I'm the type of guy that I don't
like I told you I don't dwell on
negative things and so if I think back a
lot of people do Ayahuasca to deal with
past trauma or things that are inside of
them that they feel are agitated yeah I
don't really feel like I have a lot of
that stuff but that's probably because I
don't ever think about it so I knew that
deep downside there was probably things
inside of me that I just wasn't giving
any you know attention to and so I was
like all right let's dig into this and
see you know what happens and Ayahuasca
is uh
yeah have you ever done it
no I've done I've done like heroic doses
of shrooms multiple times but I haven't
done Ayahuasca so Ayahuasca is different
than shrooms in the sense that it's more
of a
you there's definitely a psychedelic
component to it but it's more of a a DMT
release where you're you're able to
basically remove yourself from yourself
and take a look it's like a surgeon you
know coming into the hospital taking a
look at his patient and saying here's
the problem there's the problem boom
let's go in there and uh so we did the
ceremony typically when you do a
ceremony by Ayahuasca that everybody sit
around with a shaman and he plays the
drum and sings and everybody's just kind
of hanging out it's very hippie you know
feeling the way that we did it anyways
um and they make it like I said a
ceremony it's not like I would ever or
an individual would ever go by
themselves and drink Ayahuasca that's
not usually the way it's done I'm sure
people do it that way but in order to
have a good experience you got to have
the control to set in the setting right
so we do it and they're passing the cup
around and it's terrible it is the most
disgusting thing I don't like bitter
anything bitter like even olives are do
better for me I don't I don't do bitter
um and it's that's funny it's super
bitters so it's it's you know it's a
poison uh I don't say it's a poison but
it's it's
it basically is poison to your body and
it makes your body wanna you know
um
you know vomit and and get rid of
whatever's inside of you yeah so the
past couple rounds drink the first cup
nothing looking around the room people
are kind of starting to days off a
little bit after the first cup okay
second cup comes around boom nothing so
me and my partner Diesel Dave who you
met on the last podcast that we did with
you he's a big bearded guy he's sitting
across the room for me I'm sitting next
to my wife and uh cup comes around again
third time and at this point everybody's
just like
in la la land like yeah what is having
their own journey and he and I are
looking at each other like you feeling
anything well no you no no so we're
sitting there oh no completely like
unfazed because we're bigger guys I'm
240 pounds and you know we were told
that it hits everybody differently so
after the third uh cup I was like this
is dominant we're like four hours into
the ceremony I was like I'm going to bed
so I go upstairs uh we were at a cabin
and I go to my room and the Shaman's
like no no you can't don't do it I was
just like dude like this isn't working
let me let me be let me just let me go
go to bed
I got to lay down and as soon as I close
my eyes I see the Matrix I see all like
a binary code like ones and zeros ones
and zeros and I was like I'm just tired
and I'm just tired yeah and then from
there I I opened my eyes and my hand was
like uh you ever seen a goofy movie
um I was literally everything was the
same color in the same animation as the
Goofy movie like I literally felt like I
was in a cartoon and I was like oh boy
um and so I didn't fight it I knew that
it was happening and I just sat back and
said all right let's let's do this
because I was told kind of what to
expect and kind of how to handle it and
I didn't want to try to steer this
journey right I didn't say oh I gotta do
this I gotta do that because I went in
there just knowing that if something
needed to come out it would come out and
I would deal with it and literally it
just took me on a kind of a a wild 10
000 foot view of my life starting when I
was a kid and it just started bringing
up weird little childhood memories that
I didn't really even know that I
remembered and
grown-up Dave saw those memories like oh
that's that's a concern like that's
that's that was a trauma that was an
issue that was something that stuck with
you that's not an issue and I was able
to go stamp stamp stamp stamp and just
basically go one
traumatic memory at a time and say
that's okay that's okay that's okay and
the world the one that stood out the
most to me was my mom dropping me off
for the first well pretty much the whole
first year of kindergarten like I
hated that for some reason I just felt
abandoned I was told mama's boy I was
the youngest and apparently that was
something that really really stuck with
me and it caused me to act certain ways
even as I got older
um as a fear of Abandonment so I was
able to take a look at that and say hey
like little Dave you're okay like your
mom still loved you she was she picked
you up from school everything was okay
everything worked out you didn't
understand it then but you understand it
now so that's that's why I think
Ayahuasca is so cool because rather than
just seeing shapes and colors and I did
see shapes and colors but you also had a
purpose I was able to go in there and do
some actual work on myself that I didn't
know needed to be done so that was my uh
psychedelic experience
um and it was everybody you know people
who do Ayahuasca typically do it
multiple times because they love to be
able to go in there after I was done
I knew that I was done I knew that I
didn't need to do it again because
that's just the confirmation that I got
but I'll tell you this the days and
weeks after doing Ayahuasca is some of
you might like
like 20 20 Vision it is the most Crystal
Clear you'll ever see and feel and think
so that was that was pretty much it
do you have advice for say men in their
early 20s
yes
um
the world is a way different place now
than when I was in my 20s
um
it's interesting because a really good
example of this is when I was in my
early 20s NASCAR was still like huge
like the one of the highest paid biggest
money you know Sports out there
um you know 10 15 years later NASCAR is
all but dead I mean the the audience
isn't there and so that's the reason I
bring up that example is because
something as big and as as
um
eclectic and exciting as you know being
a Nascar fan
can change and it can go away and so you
have to realize that the world is not
the same place that it was when your
brother was in his 20s or your dad was
in his 20s and so
for me it is
the best thing that you can do and it's
really hard sometimes is
reach out and find Opportunities to help
the other people around you accomplish
what they want and that that sounds kind
of generic but I'll dive in a little bit
deeper it's
if you have friends or family or
co-workers
start to ask questions about
what they're working towards and what
they want because if you start lifting
up the people that you're around even
and I don't mean like it doesn't have to
be big Grand things but learning and
caring
um I think empathy is something that
is kind of
very rare these days
um simply because
there's a lot of you know division in
our cultures and whether just whether it
be in the US or other countries there's
a lot of division and people are being
taught that if
if you don't see your actual see the
what in the world the way that I do or
act the way that I do that's bad and
you're part of that tribe and it's it's
like a bunch of
tribal Warfare so
learn
what other people are working towards
and help them accomplish those goals and
understand that
if you have the tribal mentality of this
is my Elaine and that's your lane and
you're different than me and mine mine
is better because this this
that that is very toxic thinking and
uh one way to kind of cure that is then
this is what I did because we're members
of the Church of Jesus Christ AKA The
Mormons um when we're 19 we get sent to
other countries to go uh act as
missionaries so when I was 19 I got sent
down to uh the Amazon rainforest in
Bolivia in Brazil and I lived in a mud
Shack and I learned I learned the value
of you know a plate of rice and beans
and I learned that in most other
countries they eat the bones in the
chicken and they they don't waste
anything so immerse yourself in
cultures that are completely different
than yours I like that I think that is
the number one thing that somebody could
do as a young person without family and
responsibility
go put yourself you know be a foreign
exchange student go go work abroad
whatever you can do because that will
open your eyes
to
Humanity it'll it'll help you better
understand
why it's so important to
to realize that
you're not just like your lane isn't the
only correct one and your tribe isn't
the only correct one go just literally
dive as deep as you can into it because
everybody I've ever met and known that's
done that
is a better person for it and they have
better people skills and they have a
better understanding of how and why
things happen and it's uh it's hard
because
in this day and age
we get what we consume so we get more
and more of what we consume based off of
what the algorithm wants to give us
everybody has social media right and if
I like dogs and I click on a dog it's
going to give me more dogs and so if I
am clicking on things that are negative
or not healthy for me it's going to
continue to serve more and more of that
which is why I stay away from
um Party politics it's it's the most
like if you think about it
it is the most primitive caveman
thing in the entire world like the way
that the the Republicans the Democrats
talk about each other it is wild and
we're sitting here putting up with it so
I think a lot of that type of thinking
would go away if if people just get out
there and experience like yeah what your
life is like you know what I mean so
that's my best advice it's it's get out
there and serve help other people
because everything else just falls into
place that's what I did I'm not a smart
guy I'm not I'm not a super talented guy
I'm not a guy with a ton of training I
just put myself out there and I wanted
to figure out how to help other people
whether it was being a missionary and
you know teaching about the gospel or
going out and you know helping with
flood relief in in Texas and New Orleans
if you do that I'm telling you you can
be the dumbest least talented person in
the room and you'll probably be the most
successful that is I really like that
yeah it worked for me that's my story I
I really I really agree with that too I
think it's like I thought I was I have
like I'm a pretty open person and I was
like I'm pretty open right and I'm not
very conservative so but when I traveled
and went to cultures that were like
vastly different and I mean like not
like going to different places in the
U.S or to like London or something I
mean like going to Eastern Europe or
something
um I was I was like blown away at how
different cultures are
like it shocked me and I was like 26 at
that point so it's not like I was 20 and
like my eyes opened I was just like oh
people are a lot more different than I
thought they could be from each other
and it doesn't mean that one way is
right no it means it means that every
way has its Beauties every every culture
has so many beautiful things about it so
why would we it's again it goes back to
the caveman mentality why would we sit
in our own little circle
and Hyper focus on the things that we
don't like about other people when
instead we could expand our thinking and
go focus on the beautiful things about
other people it's it's literally the
exact same amount of effort if not
easier to focus on the beautiful things
and you become such a happier person you
become somebody that people want to be
around think about this if for any of
your listeners
if you're having
struggles in your social life if you're
having strife and arguments and constant
you feel like you're always running into
a wall
think about what you're focusing on in
you know a bunch of different areas okay
take uh take Sports take politics take
your hobby take your neighborhood take
work take all those different things and
think about what you think about most
okay
if you think about work and you you are
always constantly thinking about how bad
you hate that job and you can't wait to
get a new job well it's easy to take
that and flip it and and think about how
awesome your new job could be and how
what you're doing now is going to be
just a step to to get you there it's
these are small moments of refraining
the way that you view hey okay okay I've
got a I've got a comment on that
um uh I think I was working on an app
for a while that I decided not to
release uh because I'm working on
something else but what the app did is
it helped you identify areas in your
life so like your relationship your
career your health and then it helped it
it measured how happy you were on each
of those scales so like maybe you score
a three on your relationship because
you're not happy with your relationship
so you identify where the problems are
in your life and then you take that
problem and you figure out the steps you
need to take in order to solve that
problem so rather than thinking of the
problem as some sort of thing that's
going to be stuck with you forever
that's going to make your life fail you
just reframe it and turn it into oh well
that's what I should be working towards
solving and it turns it into a kind of
more
like a more positive problem than just
this thing that's weighing you down and
I think part of the way I got out of
having the autoimmune disorder was I was
like okay well I'm stuck with this like
this is me I'm stuck with it and it was
ruining my life like every aspect of my
life and so I decided to figure out you
know do whatever I needed to do to fix
it
right but anyway thank goodness it
worked so there's a there's a simple way
to do that and that's exactly what I'm
trying to do what I'm what you're saying
to me right now is exactly
what people need to do and exactly what
I started doing and the very most basic
sample way to do that is to do this
wake up
start your day as soon as something hits
you uh that creates for me it's dread
dread is my most dread and frustration
are my two most powerful emotions that
cause me to do stupid things and they
and they they literally I feel like when
I feel those two things I'm in a cement
box and I can't move and I can't make
any progress
catalog those emotions or those feelings
or those triggers if if going down the
road from here's one actually that I
cataloged
um I learned this from from a hypnotist
um and not like the guy at the carnival
but like an actual like therapeutic
hypnotist that does um hypnosis on
people for that's cool to help overcome
things and he said look just just grab a
hold of whatever that negative thing is
throughout the day uh and for me the
first thing I noticed was a pothole on
the on the road down from my house I
would hit it every single day and it
would just instantly like there'd be a
Rattle and a shake in my truck and it
would just pissed me off and I would let
it piss me off and and I didn't realize
that I was letting his mouth he says
take those things all those triggers
throughout the day
look at them
grab them acknowledge them and then put
them on a shelf behind you doesn't mean
that you're doesn't mean that you're
erasing them or or ignoring them or but
it also doesn't mean that you're giving
them a ton of time and attention take it
acknowledge it recognize it make a
mental note of it and put it on a shelf
throughout the day grab those little
things that that you're catching
yourself feeling whether like I said
their negative emotions or
um negative things that you're thinking
or seeing and just put them on a shelf
and at the end of the day you'll you'll
be able to look back and you'll realize
that the Shelf isn't nearly as full as
you thought it was especially if you're
in a really bad place if you're in a
really bad mindset
you're going to think that your shelf is
going to be Chuck full of of all sorts
of different things it's not my I had
like four items on my shelf that really
were things that were just triggering me
and I thought that I I thought if you
would have asked me back then I would
have said I got a hundred things that
are bothering me but didn't It's usually
the same thing over and over again just
presenting itself in different forms so
um I think a very powerful exercise is
to recognize it acknowledge it
um because if you try to bury it we all
know what happens it's just gonna you
know come back out even stronger and and
nastier but if you acknowledge it and
get a little bit of time and say you're
right that is that is something that's
affecting me and then you set it aside
to be able to
to then work through it is it is one of
the most powerful things I've ever done
um and so it goes right back to what you
were saying is
it's where we're looking is where we're
going right if you're driving your car
and you're looking down the road you're
going to go down the road but if you're
looking over you know in a field you'll
start to drift off you're looking down
on your phone you'll start to drift and
it's it's it's so simple and that sounds
way too simple but I promise you that is
the way it works what you're looking at
whether it be physically with your eyes
or mentally with your emotions and
thoughts that's where you're going
so just be aware of what those things
are what you think about is what you
become that's where you end up
I like that okay Dave
if people are not familiar with you
where should they go online to find you
so YouTube is where we're doing a lot of
our uh most relevant content right now I
have a Instagram at heavy dsparks
Facebook uh page it's called Heavy D
both those pages are verified they've
got like three to four million followers
on each of them so you'll be able to
know which one they are
um but YouTube is is the really fun one
for me right now and that's one where
you'll be able to get a better idea of
what I say when I say that I'm not a
just a truck guy like you know one day
we're looking for the body of a missing
person and the next day we're finding
the body of a missing person and the
next day we're we're jumping monster
trucks it's just a it's a smorgasbord of
of our life and and the best part about
it is we became one of the fastest
growing YouTube channels in the world uh
when we started posting back in
end of 2020
um you know we're growing every month
it's anywhere between 100 to 200 000 new
subscribers wow um and it's because
we're creating content for everybody you
know the crime junkie moms that stay
home and listen to murder podcasts all
day all the way to the Gear heads to the
old guys that wish they were gold miners
we we do it all and it's not forced it's
not me looking for like hey how can I
talk to this group how can I talk to
that group it's me saying oh wow that
gold mine is really cool I want to go
explore it next thing you know boom it's
blowing up so definitely check out the
YouTube channel Heavy D Sparks there's
stuff on there for literally everyone
and and you may not believe me but once
you go to the channel even you Michaela
I think you would go there and you would
be like wow this is I had no idea that I
was interested in you know this missing
person or whatever it is or or the
exploration of an old mind
um and one thing I'm really proud of is
the cinematography I've got an
incredible media team and and every
single video that we make whether it's
just a dump stunt or something very
meaningful feels like a miniature movie
and that's cool yeah so that's something
we're really proud of and we're
continuing to get into that we're
getting ready to do some mini docky
series on some some really twisted stuff
that's that's happened uh with missing
people and stuff that we're aware of
stuff that you would see like on Netflix
but we're just gonna do it for free and
put it on YouTube because it's good
practice for us and and we want to
continue to sharpen that ax and get
really really good so
long story short
think
I went from being you know a TV
Automotive container Entertainer to I
want to be a Storyteller I want to be
able to tell stories you're good at it
thank you this has been very
entertaining you're good at it it's one
thing that I'm really trying to focus on
because it's something that I enjoy and
if I enjoy it other people can enjoy it
because they'll feel my energy and my
passion just like you I love listening
to your podcast especially you know some
of the episodes you've done with your
dad because you can feel that there's
just this like excitement in the room
because you love what you're doing you
guys absolutely are passionate about it
and I think that's that's you know a
final piece of advice for anybody
listening is
if if what you're doing isn't working
think about
do you enjoy it yeah are you are you
having fun doing it does it get you
excited does it keep you up at night if
it doesn't
you know maybe it's time for a change
Maybe not maybe maybe you do need to
stick with that and grind through
whatever you're working on but uh the
more excited you are about something
the more excited everybody else is going
to be about it as well so that's that's
what works for me
yeah I like that and people can stick it
in too like if you can't you can't just
necessarily quit your job and focus on
your hobby but you could maybe
focused on your hobby for half an hour a
day or like 45 minutes a day and just
see where it goes when you start paying
attention to it okay that brings me to
one thing I got to mention because you
do have what's your audience your
audience is
um like 25 to 35 year olds mainly but
then it kind of goes out from there and
on YouTube 70 men okay so it's male
heavy yeah so this is good these are my
people these are the guys that I talk to
all the time
um and this is something that bothers me
like crazy in in today's culture you
hear a lot about side hustles you got to
have a side hustle you gotta yeah two or
three side hustles I
disagree with that there's nothing wrong
with the side hustle if it works for
your current lifestyle and what you're
doing and what's going on but I think so
many people and I I say this because I
employ a lot of people and I've had a
lot of people work for me and I see them
all start their side hustles and the
majority of those people that start the
side hustles end up lacking here like
there could be somebody that I was gonna
learn to move up to a great position
with you know a huge raise and I see
them start a side hustle and within
three to six months they are usually
gone they're no longer working for me so
just know that
you don't have to have a side hustle
your side hustle instead could be
converted into doing your job better
because you don't know what's around the
corner if you if you have a job where
you know or even if you don't know that
there's room for advanced advancement
just know that
take that energy because it's there
right the side hustle energy and and if
you have a great idea for a side hustle
and you think that's what you want to do
and go do it but if you don't or if
you're not sure
in the meantime take that energy and put
it into what you're doing do what you're
doing the very best and don't do it
half-assed and all of a sudden yeah
these are going to start to come to you
and happen that you would have never
expected I've had guys in my
organization a few of them that instead
of taking the side hustle route they
they dug their heels in and worked
harder for me and those guys are in
significantly better positions now and
they're getting paid more than double
what they're getting paid uh you know
back then so it's uh it
it's very valuable to be
to create value for somebody in a
business and just know that you don't
not everybody's an entrepreneur there's
there's entrepreneurs there's people
that can work within a business and be
way more valuable in that business than
they would be able to be on their own so
that's uh that's what's something that
guys need to hear because there's almost
like a shame yeah
okay I like that I'm glad you brought
that up now like I'm glad you brought
that up because it's true and also a lot
of side houses hustles are just a waste
of time in general so you have to be
like specific about what you're what
you're working on
um but I think one of the ways that
people can become more valuable is to
figure out where a problem is like if
you're working for this is what I did
working for my dad and then I managed to
like I managed to grow that business
student massively right and all I really
did was I saw a problem and I was like
okay I'll fix that I'll do that like I
can do that oh hey this is annoying you
I'll take that over or you're working on
this I can do that for you and then when
I've hired people because they're a
bunch of people working under me now the
people who are really valuable are
people who say oh there's a problem I'll
I'll handle that and I'm like fantastic
now I don't have to do it that's exactly
or educated you just have to spot
problems that people are having and say
I'll take that away from you yeah rather
than that working on them yeah yeah you
become somebody who can say a that's
something that I can take on I can
handle it that's that's like I said the
guys my most valuable guys
are the people that
found the dumb things the stupid little
things that I would trip over and they
made it go away and yeah those guys
they're gonna have I'm always going to
take care of those people and to be
honest with you I'll probably be able to
take care of some of those guys
significantly better than they would be
able to take care of themselves on their
own that makes sense
yeah so cool okay Dave it was nice
talking to you thank you so much for
coming on absolutely it's my pleasure to
talk with you
[Music]
thank you